نشاهده الان على الصوره
مباشره رشقه صاروخيه على ما يبدو
هبه هل انت معي
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم هو
اطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه العمق
الاسرائيلي باتجاه
المناطق
ليست المحاذيه نستطيع ان نتحدث عن ارتفاع
شديد واندفاع شديد لهذه الصواريخ على ما
يبدو انها اكثر عمقا من الصواريخ التي سبق
اطلاقها قبل قليل من قطاع غزه كانت
المقاومه قد تحدثت وكما تحدثت قبل قليل
بان المقاومه وسرايا القدس قالت بان
استمرار اطلاق الصواريخ واستمرار الرد على
استهدافات الجيش الاسرائيلي للمنازل
المواطنين ولقطاع غزه بوتيره متسارعه
سيكون له رد بالتاكيد ونحن نلاحظ هذا الرد
سريعا باطلاق هذه الصواريخ رشقات من
الصواريخ انطلقت من قطاع غزه ورشقات ايضا
من القذائف الصاروخيه في المناطق الحدوديه
باتجاه المناطق المحيطه بقطاع غزه منذ
صباح اليوم وحتى الان تم اطلاقها من قبل
المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ونتابع ايضا انه استمرار
الرشقات الصاروخيه في نفس الوقت الذي
تستمر فيه الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه الحديث عن استهدافات لاراضي زراعيه
واراضي فارغه كما كان يحدثنا الزملاء طوال
الوقت الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه يستهدف
منصات لاطلاق هذه الصواريخ ويستهدف
الاراضي التي تستخدمها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولكن كانت المحاوله
لمنع اطلاق الصواريخ
للحد من قدره هذه الفصائل على استمرار
اطلاق الصواريخ ولكن نحن نلاحظ ان هذه
الغارات تتزامن تحديدا مع اطلاق الصواريخ
من قطاع غزه من قبل عناصر المقاومه باتجاه
عمق صافرات الانذار تدوي الان في عسقلان
نسال الياس كرام عما يجري
[موسيقى]
الياس في الدقائق الاخيره هنا في جنوب
عسقلان وهنالك مجموعه من الصواريخ التي
انطلقت صوب المناطق الجنوبيه للمدينه كانت
هنالك بعض الاعتراضات من فوقنا لمنظومه
القبه الحديديه
وهذه
الدفعات الصاروخيه تاتي بعد ساعات من
الهدوء النسبي هنا في جنوب عسقلان وفي
بلدات القريبه من غلا في غزاله تجدد هذا
القصف الصاروخي من قطاع غزه باتجاه
المناطق الشماليه والشماليه الشرقيه
للقطاع
الاستهدافات كانت حقيقه للمناطق الجنوبيه
لعسقلان وكانت هنالك بالفعل بعض المناطق
التي تعرضت
له هذه الصواريخ هنالك منظومه القبه
الحديديه تمكنت كما شاهدنا من اعتراض
ثلاثه صواريخ في هذه المنطقه التي نقف
فيها في منطقه الى الجنوب من عسقلان
والتوقعات بالفعل كانت ان استمرار اسرائيل
في هذه الغارات الجويه التي تستهدف بلدات
في تستهدف عده مواقع في قطاع غزه وتحديدا
منازل لم تكشف حتى الان عن طبيعه الاهداف
التي تقصفها في هذه الشقق السكنيه وفي هذه
الاحياء
السكنيه الامنه نحن ننتظر ربما ببيانات
رسميه من الجيش الاسرائيلي لمعرفه ما الذي
يجري هناك هنالك سلسله من الغارات الجويه
المكثفه والمتتاليه التي يقوم بها سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي منذ اكثر من ساعه في
اهداف في داخل قطاع غزه استهدافات لشقق
سكنيه يبدو انها عمليات اغتيال سوف نتحقق
من ذلك او ربما تكون استهدافات لبعض غرف
العمليات وغرف التحكم والمراقبه التي يدار
تدار منها هذه العمليه من جانب الجهاد
الاسلامي